STEPHANIE WONG:
What's up, everyone.
Thanks for checking out "This
Week In Cloud," where we serve
you the lowest latency news.
Our Google Cloud
Platform region in Zurich
is now live and
ready for business.
Let's do this with numbers.
It's our sixth European
region, and our 19th worldwide.
And the Zurich GCP region comes
with three availability zones.
But the coolest number,
hosting applications here
can improve latency
for Swiss end users
by up to 10 milliseconds.
You'll have access to
our flagship products
such as Google Compute
Engine, Google Kubernetes
Engine, BitQuery, and so on.
But best of all, thanks
to Cloud Interconnect,
you can even access the services
that aren't available in Zurich
yet by connecting to other
regions over the Google
network.
Try it out and reach
end users worldwide.
You might know that Google wrote
the book on site reliability
engineering.
And now we're adding
some new chapters.
We've just added a new
Coursera course on SRE
to help engineers design and
manage complex systems that
meet their reliability targets.
Basically it distills
everything we've
learned through trial and
error about SRE since we
coined the term itself.
These best practices are tried
and true, so check them out.
Not sure where to get started
on these best practices?
Our Google Cloud
partners have access
to lots of great
resources, including
helping you discover new
solutions for your customers
and new channels for your
business with Google Cloud.
Our SLO guide is a free
resource for our partners
to help companies
discover what they should
measure based on common
architectures and critical user
journeys.
So if you want to see what
being a Google Cloud partner
can do for you, take a look at
the path to becoming a partner.
Speaking of better SRE,
have you tried out Istio
and see how it can support
your SRE practices?
Check out this awesome
blog from our Istio series
to discover how
to easily surface
application metrics with Istio
and Stackdriver monitoring.
You'll even learn how
to track the progression
of a single request as it's
handled by our other services
in your deployment
with Stackdriver Trace,
while Stackdriver
Logging can give you
a more complete picture of what
your app is doing at all times.
Read the blog post, and try
out the hands-on tutorial
for yourself.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Have thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the cloud.